we were talking about the way that the
labour party is trying to navigate its
way on the path back to power in a
landscape with echoes of the 1970s and
the 1980s
delegates could do worse than listen to
some of the parties elder states people
including our next guest charles clark
was a labour councillor worked as chief
of staff to neil kinnick in opposition
became an mp himself and served as
education secretary and home secretary
under tony blair
you could say he's seen it and done it
all
and he joins us now
charles clark
how do you think they're doing so far
this weekend well first of all trevor
good morning nice to see you in the
fresh sunday morning
i think they're doing okay i think
politics has been exceptionally
difficult in the time of covid this is
the first really large person-to-person
gathering that's taken place
there are many many issues which need to
be resolved uh on some of them you've
covered in this program today
but i think they've put themselves up as
a realistic alternative to the
conservatives and that's what they need
to be at this stage they need to take it
further now to really set out what the
alternatives are there's more work to do
well i want to come to that but if i may
first
deal with the the issue of the moment
you
were have been you were a minister for a
long time this weekend the country faces
a petrol crisis prospectus shortages in
the supermarket um
you
actually faced a rather more challenging
christ set of crises at home at home
secretary the fuel duty crisis foot and
and when you were party chairman so on
um what would you be advising the
cabinet to be doing right now
get real look at the absolute situation
uh in a sense grant shap's got off a bit
light he's the puppet and the puppet
master the organ grinder is pretty patel
the home secretary the whole issue here
is about the immigration criteria and
under what basis you can give people the
right to work in this country brexit
made the decision clear it wasn't the eu
it was the british government so the
question is could this have been
predicted well yes it could you gave
earlier today the example of uh branch
chaps himself predicting it in august so
if it could be predicted why didn't the
steps weren't steps in place earlier
secondly why is it so few we're talking
about 4 000 or so
road drivers when there are 100 000
drivers short when we've got 13 000
drivers less than when we were last in
the eu from the eu and then finally why
only these sectors why only uh
road drivers and uh poultry what about
care workers you've been talking to
christina just now there's significant
shortages across the economy the
government has it in its power to
resolve those questions right now and
pretty patellars held out to say no
change no change no change no change
until yesterday morning when the prime
minister overruled her and said they put
in the scheme that they're announcing
this morning too little too late you've
got to face up to the issue predict it
get on the case beforehand and then pull
out all the stops at the moment the
government isn't pulling out any stops
at all it's it it's various injunctions
as to how people should behave but the
reality is when we had those issues in
autumn 2000 on the field drivers dispute
the foot and mouth crisis we pulled out
all the stops at that time whatever
problem was needed including up to
including using the army if necessary to
help move things forward i don't see any
evidence that grant traps himself or his
organ grinder priti patel are taking
these issues at all seriously do you
think that's the core point do you think
pretty patel is up to it of course she
isn't she's been a hopeless home
secretary and she should have been sat
the last time around all the
commentators just a couple of weeks ago
all the commentators rightly say that
she's got some grip on boris johnson
he's frightened of her in the back
benches or whatever it might be which
means she's unstackable as far as boris
johnson's concerned but her track record
is appalling it was appalling through
covid uh in the whole way she dealt with
policing the civil liberties issued
through kovid it's appalling on
immigration crossing the
channel it's appalling on this issue now
she is the person who has the
responsibility for the quotas of people
allowed to get visas in this country and
on what basis it is she's deciding that
she's been overruled by the prime
minister for this short announcement
we've got this morning uh but she is the
person who's responsible and people like
grant chaps aren't pulling the true
calling the tricks at all they're simply
uh doing what she said let's come back
to labor you and neil kinnick's chief of
staff
at the time when
the now very famous speech uh denouncing
militant uh
took took place or delivered that that
speech and you in fact had been
in liverpool trying to
deal with the problem as you saw it of
the far left the militant and so on now
it's pretty clear that the party
leadership wants to try to tackle
a similar problem now if you were neil
kinnick's chief of staff now what would
you be a neil king a big partner
kirsten's chief of staff now what would
you be advising him to do firstly you
have to prepare in each case in each
area it's policy it's organization it's
communication you have to prepare that's
what we did on liverpool for that speech
about militant that that you referred to
with neil that applies to the
constitutional changes we're talking
about i'm in favor of what's going to go
through today i hope because i think
it's a step in the right direction i
think here's done well to put it on the
agenda but you've got to prepare very
fully and very comprehensive you can't
just bounce it on everybody
secondly the outstanding issues that
still remain a large number of
disciplinary cases in the labour party
about anti-semitism and so on thousands
i gather still unresolved i would say
those have to be resolved and sorted out
categorically they can't hang about in
all of these issues as they have to move
forward that's on the organizational
side on the policy side you have to
develop in each area of policy in an
alternative of what we would be doing we
labor would be doing were we in
government now so it's no good simply
attacking opposing by attacking the
government and saying you're a load of
rubbish they are a load of rubbish but
that's not enough you've got to say if
we were there we'd be doing this in a
different way whether it's the migration
dispute whether it was what we're
talking about today the fuel drivers
dispute or whatever on every area we
have to say to the british people there
is a better way of doing this uh dealing
with this problem and we would be doing
it in this way on cop26 when it comes
around on security the foreign policy
issues whatever it is and that has to
emerge
weakly as it comes through it's not a
great policy for the future it's a sense
of what the labor alternative is we get
a sense of that i get the sense that um
you don't think that actually that's
what we're getting this weekend instead
what we are probably going to get is 24
hours of conversation about
the word scum now you've just used the
word rubbish about government
do you think that that kind of language
helps in any way
in general no and i try and censor
myself sometimes sometimes
unsuccessfully on those kinds of things
but i i don't think that's the right way
to proceed but i think it is fair for an
opposition to say is the government
competent in dealing with this question
so in the case of what we're just
talking about now is the government
competent in dealing with the migration
issue with the fuel dispute issue or
whatever if it's not competent we should
draw attention to it but this is a but
this is uh i'm really really
asking a question about the way that
politics is projected
um this is going to hang over the labour
leadership for some time isn't it
is the deputy leader a person that you
can trust to put out there
she certainly is i i think it may hang
over it depends what people like you and
how people like you talk about it i
wasn't aware about till i heard it you
mentioned on this program today it's not
an enormous issue
as i'm sure andrew herself would say
today it's not the right way to conduct
yourself in these circumstances and
she'd seek to
control herself in a way that ensured
that bad language of that kind or my use
of the word rubbish is not used uh
because that's a bad way of conducting
politics but i don't think it's the
central question the central question is
what are the policies government
actually doing and what should labour be
offering as an alternative charles clark
thank you very much thank you